okay let's come back
Nova's working whereas a coffee I've tea
mint green tea happy Halloween 98 yeah
Bishop c4 Queen f3 down the piece will I
have a maid threats
I think I want to play h4 h4 h5 also
ideas a Bishop g5 OG v f6 it's
interesting
a bishop a3 - yeah there are some moves
to consider what to do maybe King f1
just getting off the the file yeah King
f1 now where is box Queen going cuz f6
f6 I just take and win stuff Queen a3 I
take so Queen off they probably only
move to play rook e1 feels like black is
suffering
it's very much stuck in this position
despite being up a piece it is a
question though like what is White's
plan there's no immediate like targets
like ok black wants to play b6 in Bishop
e7 so I think the plan is to play f4 f5
I also play d5 immediately like d5 d6 so
maybe what I can do
start with Queen d3 preventing b5 along
enough pawn to move forward and also if
I get in this then the F pawn is tied
down to the night so the question is do
I play a4 or d5 both look very
attractive I'll play d5 I think this is
very direct like the King's just stuck
in the center the Queen's on a fades ie6
is very hard to stop hello to Elvin
spell and hello to past life karma if
you just got here yeah this is a
Halloween gambit celebrating Halloween
early trying to have some fun trying to
recover from the previous game black and
legally castle kind of forgot about that
but if black castles I probably just
take em oh it's interesting
huh oh I have a nice idea to take y'all
take first does it kind of does it work
wait a minute it's complicated
also have a 7 e 7 d 6 yada yada I can
also take on each six on so many options
not sure I'm trying to calculate takes
[Music]
let's take your first it was difficult
decision
okay now d6 unleashing the bishop oh I
got mated I got mated where'd that come
from
I got made had no idea block was
sweating meat had no awareness of my
weakness what was that that's so tragic
I was debating between d6 and Queen
takes and Bishop III even like this move
boo
Oh two losses in a row okay
oh and what did you let's play e4 okay
Halloween time I think my last Halloween
gambit I lost so this is time for
redemption
d5 best move I think I've studied this
but I forgot what to do
maybe I just take I take with Bishop and
there's like Bishop before k c6 looks
like a move yeah the goal is just to
brag about my beautiful center pawns
castle ideas f4 f5 not f5 coming but do
I care I kind of care
wait 94 idea of c3 also idea of 96
multi-purpose
I can play off for now it's a nice
formation f5 his idea to almost traps
tonight yes there's 97 f5 while I want
to play C 4 F 5 is actually probably a
good move because I don't want to take
on pissant even though it might be the
best move thinking like G 3 I'll play
Knight G 3 because now my center of
pawns are pretty pretty stable and I
play c4 and just keep expanding like a
trademark Halloween gambits down the
piece but the pawns are compensation but
now what do I do
black wants to play Bishop g7 and Castle
I have a d5 maybe Rock a 5 or K 5 the
rook is a bit loose so what to do H 5 H
4
I'm not seeing a clear plan I mean let's
play Queen f3 rook d1 and then try some
day for d5 maybe okay this is my plan
put all the pieces to prepare the d5
push King f7 unexpected pretty sure
block yeah lock illegally castle there
and black is castling by hand okay so
I'm executing my plan in hopes of
executing my opponent I have upon d5 now
d5 supported now this is nice nice
formation I want to play Knight b5 soon
at some points unless this is played so
there's e6 or d6 or doing something else
what to do
Bishop c5 Bishop c5 before think with
the dark side Bishop my pawns are
happier in light squares interesting so
II 6 here or b4 first trying to
calculate but it's difficult you rook
there go play rook d3 seems like a
random move but I want to double up
support the D pawn I'm pretty sure if
takes rook t1 should win back material
38 seconds
yeah b4 is called for now maybe e6 yeah
II 66 the pawns are rolling like a
bowling ball
these are my pins
hey it's a sub Deadman DM thanks for
subbing again 15 months and the ponds
and these ponds feel so good I don't
want to lose them and I'm guaranteed to
win something because if the knight
moves east islands of fork yeah let's
play you seven I don't even want to take
the bishop but maybe I should I'm
conflicted yeah let's just take the
bishop the proper decision maybe this
move b5 now this might is a bit awkward
if it moves back it cuts off the defense
of the rook and I can take on d6 so his
might just trapped if it moves back
either way I take on b6 the night might
just be trapped yeah apologies for the
twitch lag' hopefully wasn't too bad
I should be not lagging anymore I think
that's one of the symptoms of jet lag
rook f6 ok went from being down the
piece to being up a piece and now just
winning more stuff on two pieces well
the game was a nice game it's like a
very classic Halloween
gambit game maybe I'll upload this I'll
post this on Halloween this will be my
Halloween video if I remember to find it
what's my uptime I'll find it somehow
yeah for people watching on Halloween if
I don't get around to making an even
better Halloween video there's your
Halloween video for 2019
smash the like button tell me what
you're dressed up as and I'll see you in
the future